on a deux heures de chez toi alors
avec l'âne on se connaît depuis l'école
primaire c'est mon meilleur ami non
adoptées en faisant que cassandra lina
ma meilleure amie pourtant dix
rencontres est un vilan m'a vachement
parler toi c'est quoi
bon
la cendre à une bouger et vous n'y
mettez là un pacte
[Musique]
qui ta copine la jeune hina c'est ma
meilleure amie lucie nantes je vais
ramener cassandra chez elle se sent pas
de rentrer cette somme basile et perd
pas l'atteindre fois qu'il a dit je
reviens vite il a passé la nuit avec
elle les perd pas être plus près et ses
cols
deux communes tags de saumon scène comme
si j'avais une carte event à gifi et là
ça me rend dingue
je veux pas rester indéfiniment commencé
entre ta mère pattie 3,6 soit 9 3 mois
enfin nous avons beaucoup en commun cinq
minutes la rigolade la complicité entre
auxquelles je crois qu'on s'est pas
compris en faveur de la gratuité
lina ces mouches en avant qu'à
débarquement par les agents 4 je vais
finir touche à mon poste c'est dingue je
te mets des ventes depuis ce2 et la
seule fois où tu m'emmerdes j'ai envie
de crever carrément
dylan et cassandra et imaginent ils se
mettent ensemble ils ont un gosse obligé
ils appellent qu'elles viennent